Hi everyone, I'm Stefan from the Flugschule Frewings flight school, and today I want to talk a bit about aerodynamics.
Aerodynamics in general, but above all paraglider-specific.
The question that surely concerns all of us — how does a paraglider actually fly?
Ever since the first moment as a kid, when I saw a paraglider launch, I couldn't let go of it — I've always been fascinated.
How can it be that a wing made from a bit of fabric and a few lines, pulled out of a backpack,
lifts us into the air — how can you fly with this thing?
And once you dig into the basics, you quickly find out that a paraglider works exactly the same way.
Like an aeroplane, like a bird too — we have a wing surface that generates lift, and through that produces a force
that keeps us up in the air.
I'll compare it a bit to a car.
Everyone can drive a car, but if you really understand how the clutch and the engine and everything works in detail,
that's often quite decisive.
With the paraglider it can also happen that you're a super top pilot and don't really know
what's actually going on above you.
But I'm of the opinion that this is relatively important for paragliding.
Maybe more so than for driving a car.
So that you understand the technical background a little bit,
because it matters for safety, and also when you want to get the full performance out of the wing,
when later on you fly a bit more ambitiously and things get serious.
Having that background helps, because you'll also want to get more out of the wing.
It all started a very, very long time ago.
Otto Lilienthal started back in 1891
and he built the very first — you could almost say — hang gliders,
and he carried out the first successful flights.
Even earlier he'd started observing birds, and he noticed
that not every bird needs to flap its wings to stay in the air.
Above all he looked at the larger birds
and noticed they can do this really well —
they glide without doing anything with their wings.
Then he started — with storks from the Rhineland —
to dissect the animals and observed
that the wings of all these animals showed a certain airfoil profile.
And he then transferred that wing profile onto his own wings.
And then he discovered that you generate lift this way,
when the air flows in,
the air carries you, after taking a few running steps.
In general there are several different attempts to explain
or reasons why a wing flies.
Basically there are three approaches or three principles
for how a wing generates lift and keeps us up in the air.
The first approach is Bernoulli's theory.
We're dealing here with flow dynamics.
We have a wing profile here,
like most wing profiles.
They're asymmetric, meaning on top
we have a larger curvature than underneath.
That causes the airflow on top to have to circulate faster,
to flow faster, and there you get a low pressure.
Before that, it comes in from the front.
(unclear)
which creates a force acting on us.
The distribution is another little detail for the theory exam.
The distribution is two-thirds low pressure on the upper surface
and one-third high pressure on the underside of the wing.
It's a bit confusing in terms of the wording,
and you have to make sure you don't mix it up.
At some point the airflow begins
to follow the profile and then to detach from it.
That's called the separation point,
where a little turbulence and a bit of drag is generated.
But we'll come back to that
in more detail later.
Basically: Bernoulli's theory, flow dynamics, low pressure, high pressure —
that's the first approach.
How does a wing fly?
The second one is the recoil principle.
That's action-equals-reaction from Newton,
who figured out
that on every body,
when any force is applied, an opposing force arises.
You may have tried this yourself,
when you stick your hand out of a moving car.
Maybe not as the driver —
maybe once as a passenger,
and pay attention to exactly what happens
when you hold your hand out straight.
Not much happens —
you've probably felt that —
there's no big resistance,
because the hand surface is along the wind.
When you start angling your hand,
in one direction there's a force that pulls upward.
And if you tilt it the other way,
then your hand gets pushed downward.
And the wing uses this recoil principle too,
because in the wing there's also a certain angle
to the incoming airflow.
We call this the angle of attack —
we'll come back to that later.
And it creates a force
that points upward
and keeps us up in the air.
The third approach
for how a wing produces lift
is the so-called circulation flow.
At the sharp trailing edge of the wing,
a starting vortex develops.
And the flow is then deflected downward.
And there again you get a moment
or force pointing upward,
which also contributes to dynamic lift.
Those are the three principles
that keep the wing in the air.
Now we have a few technical terms
around wing profiles too.
Right now we're still looking at the wing
in cross-section.
Later we'll look at the whole paraglider,
the entire wing across the span as well,
and also the lines and the pilot,
the pilot hanging underneath,
and what influence all that has.
For the moment we're just looking at the cross-section.
With the paraglider,
the profile is relatively thick.
So the profile thickness — that's the blue bar.
It's relatively thick.
Compared, for example, to a fast aircraft,
to a fighter jet,
where the profile is very flat
and not very asymmetric,
and rather thinner.
So a slow aircraft,
which at low takeoff speed
already generates a lot of lift,
without needing a huge speed
to produce or generate it.
It's mostly a thick
and asymmetric profile that's chosen.
Profile depth is essentially the distance
from the front stagnation point to the rear stagnation point.
On the paraglider,
that's the leading edge and the trailing edge,
where you can see
these are terms
you'll need again and again with aircraft.
Profile chord is a theoretical concept.
It's the connecting line
from the front to the back.
Don't confuse it with profile depth.
Profile depth is just the distance, and profile chord
is really the connecting line between the two points.
Now we can move on to forces and vectors.
I briefly mentioned earlier
that several force vectors act on the wing
through lift and drag — all of these together combine
into one main vector,
the lift vector.
Or later we'll learn
that's then the aerodynamic resultant,
which is composed of lift and drag.
But more on that later.
First of all, just theoretically,
how that looks with vectors —
this is a classic theory exam question.
It works like this:
when you want
to combine forces,
or when at the same application point on a body
two different forces act,
then you can hang the forces onto each other.
We see here in the example
forces F1 and F4 acting on a body.
They have the same application point.
What is the resultant R of the two forces?
So on the left we have F1 and F4,
we pick those up,
then we have to hang them onto each other.
And see what the result is.
And if we now go from the start point to the end point
of F1,
and add F4
and then from the start point of both to the end point,
we connect them,
then we see the result —
a diagonal force
that's changed level a bit.
It's the sum of these two forces,
and in this example it's R2.
Then we have another example.
If the forces act in the same direction,
then of course it's even simpler.
Then there's no diagonal or anything,
you can just add the forces up,
for example we can count the squares here
and see F1 plus F2,
4 squares plus 2 squares,
gives 6 squares for R3.
Then we can also see
what happens when the forces act in opposite directions.
And now suppose the forces are exactly the same size.
We have some stone
and from both sides some force pushes it,
and if they're exactly equal,
then the stone stays exactly in place.
And here we see F1
is smaller, so F3 deviates a bit there.
And again we combine them.
Now you can sum the forces up
and together it gives R4.
This basic knowledge is still important
for understanding the next few slides.
Here we have again a wing, profile chord,
in the drawing, which is aerodynamically quite important.
We'll see the whole thing in a moment —
we have the aerodynamic resultant,
which I briefly mentioned earlier.
We have lift and drag.
The absolute dream case would of course be
to build a wing
that produces no drag.
So no air resistance.
But that's just not possible,
because we have a certain frontal area,
a certain surface
that the air has to push against.
And that always generates drag.
We can build as perfect a wing as we like.
We will never fully get rid of
the drag force that acts against us.
And lift and drag
combined.
We see here too,
they form a triangle.
And the diagonal of that
is the aerodynamic resultant.
What's important —
shown on the left —
lift and drag
are always at 90° to each other.
Not sometimes,
but always exactly at 90°.
Drag is always exactly
in line with the incoming airflow,
so with the flight path or with the airflow.
It always comes down to the colour,
as you can see.
It doesn't really play a role
whether the wing is in a wind tunnel
for a theoretical setup, or whether the wing
is gliding through still air.
Above all, it's always relative:
the wing relative to the air.
The centre of pressure is also important —
don't forget the centre of pressure.
It's the point
where all these forces act.
And weight force
is always equal in size
to the aerodynamic resultant.
So if we're heavier,
we need more lift,
more drag.
And the aerodynamic resultant grows too.
Now let's continue with this slide.
With the airflow direction
I mentioned briefly,
the airflow direction,
which runs in exactly the same direction
as the drag.
And here you can see the airflow now.
Here's the hand,
held a bit at an angle,
tilted a bit in this air channel
or in an airflow.
Let's look at neutral, unmoving, still air masses.
Let's look at that.
Then we can move on to the drag
of a body.
There's another interesting formula
for drag and lift.
They're always exactly
the same — at the front we have W for drag.
After that we have a few factors
that produce the drag.
Very important here,
please don't get scared.
For the theory exam,
the brevet theory exam,
you don't have to memorise any formulas
and you don't have to be able to compute in this style.
So don't be scared.
I've only drawn the formula
to show
which elements
actually combine to produce drag,
what it consists of.
First of all we have C.
That's the shape and the angle of attack.
And here it comes down to
whether it's a wing,
or a car, or some rock in the wind.
It really depends on the shape.
On how the device
or object is exposed to the wind stream.
Then we have air density in there.
With the rho —
above the P.
Air density is of course also very important.
At several different altitudes we don't have the same air density —
if we're up at 2000 metres,
because of course that affects drag too.
Then we have speed.
Careful, speed is always squared.
It has an influence as a square.
We'll come back to that
in detail,
for us with the paraglider.
And S is also still in there,
that's the area of the object.
For lift it's exactly the same.
Only the B-value,
the coefficient, changes there.
The remaining factors are the same.
Lift has a different B-value,
and that's what influences how lift behaves.
Or the force that arises
and then gives lift.
On the SHV exam question
you can find this again and again —
what happens
if you have a certain area.
It causes a certain drag in the wind.
What happens
if you double or halve the area?
And that's always relatively simple.
It's always linear.
If you double the area of an object,
the drag also doubles.
If you halve it,
the drag halves.
If you halve the air density,
because you go way, way higher,
for example when you launch the paraglider,
then the drag also halves.
A really big exclamation mark
is for speed.
When it comes to speed,
things always behave as a square.
So if speed doubles,
then all forces quadruple.
If speed triples,
then all forces become nine times as large.
I'm always urging this for a question.
Don't let the urgency lure you in,
just clicking quickly,
but look carefully:
is it about some factor
or about speed in the question.
Very important not to mix it up.
Here's an example right now.
I won't read out the whole question now,
but if we have 30 km/h
and in the second case we have 90 km/h,
then that's a tripling of the speed,
of the wind speed,
and a ninefold increase of the drag.
So from 100 Newtons it doesn't become 300 Newtons,
as you might think,
but 900.
In the meteorology course
we'll learn some very
important info about our planet's atmosphere.
For the paraglider, this affects us
in that higher up,
we have less air density
and there are fewer air particles around.
And our wing has to move faster, or through the air,
to produce the same lift.
That means,
very simply put,
you need a higher takeoff speed.
We can see from this curve
that air pressure decreases with altitude.
At 5,500 metres it's already only half as large,
and along with air pressure,
air density also decreases,
which appears in our formula too.
Air density first halves at 6,600 metres,
it halves,
so watch out not to mix them up.
But ultimately it doesn't matter,
whether it's now 5,500 metres or 6,500 metres,
for the theory exam of course it does.
But in practice it has the same effect.
The effect is
that air density decreases.
There are fewer air particles.
And somehow we have to generate our lift,
because the problem is,
if we look at the formula,
the drag coefficient
stays the same.
The area of our wing
Our weight stays the same.
That means lift,
which we can reduce
by going through the air.
It stays the same.
But our density is only about half as much,
or maybe 30% less.
That means, to get the lift up front
back to the same value.
If somehow,
we can only compensate for this one way,
we have to make up for it through speed.
It comes in handy for us
that speed is squared.
That means,
at half air density
we don't have to run twice as fast.
Just the square root of two.
Now this is getting a bit much already.
It's mathematical.
But it means,
if you launch from a high mountain
you have to be aware,
you have to run much faster.
Which usually goes against the grain a bit,
because you might already be tired,
you might have hiked up,
you might be launching in deep snow,
out front it might be steep,
but just keep it in mind:
you need more speed,
more speed
also means a longer running distance.
On the other side
you shouldn't forget the advantages.
You can handle a bit more wind
when the air density decreases.
So there are advantages too,
that you can maybe still launch up there in a 30 km/h wind
as a beginner,
whereas down at 1500 metres in 30 km/h
it would already be quite demanding
and probably not possible at launch any more.
Now we can quickly move on
to these drag coefficients,
the cw values,
as I said,
it really depends on what object
we have,
whether it's the wing or something else.
What's important is
when you compare objects
with each other,
you always
assume the same frontal area.
Here,
when you compare these,
they all have a certain drag,
when the air flows around them,
but some of them,
have much more than the others.
And that comes down to the cw value,
as I said,
also depending on the shape.
So for example a half-shell,
is 30 times,
(unclear)
It always goes — driven by gravity — towards something
that offers the least resistance.
And if you look very closely, it actually looks like a raindrop.
And the raindrop can't just fall from the sky like a flat board either,
but it also doesn't fall straight from the sky,
in a way that offers the least possible drag and the most efficient
shape it can.
And that's been put to use long ago
with the anemometer.
They use half-shells,
because if you used spheres or some sliding shapes,
for an anemometer,
they wouldn't move easily,
since the force would be the same on all sides.
But because they are half-shells,
the wind that blows into here
causes much more drag
than the wind that blows over here,
and so the little wheel starts to turn,
and that's then converted into a certain wind speed.
Here too, the formula squared,
is what gives the drag.
When we fly,
we constantly have certain angle-of-attack changes.
Normally, if you just fly the wing,
you fly at trim speed,
or at the angle of attack
the wing is built with,
or — depending on age, or when it ages and the line lengths
are no longer quite right,
then the wing's angle gets a bit larger.
But we can influence it ourselves,
for example by braking or accelerating.
When you brake, the angle of attack gets bigger,
because for example you pull down the edge, and the connecting line
from the rearmost point to the foremost point,
you change massively,
you change the flight speed and you sink more,
and the angle of attack gets bigger.
It looks roughly like this:
the wing flies slowly,
for example the ca and cw values,
get bigger.
It's very important,
also for the theory exam,
to remember:
when the wing's angle of attack gets bigger,
the values grow,
and vice versa,
when you accelerate the wing,
and the angle of attack gets smaller,
then the ca and cw values get smaller.
Very important is
to know:
we're always talking about steady glide.
So,
whether we're heavily braking,
or accelerated,
it's always stationary and the wing
is flying on a line,
in a stable state.
And then in steady glide,
the yellow arrow and the violet arrow,
so our force,
our aerodynamic resultant
and the weight force, are always equal in size.
If you come from full speed
and brake,
we know
that the wing at first
(unclear)
For us on the wing,
the stagnation point is the point
going onto the underside.
It's the apex where the flow divides.
And this point shifts of course,
it doesn't always stay the same.
It also has to do with the angle of attack.
If I increase the angle of attack here,
the point wanders further to the rear.
And now you can also see why
the paraglider's cell openings
are in the front-lower area
and not just straight at the front or on top,
because in that area,
where we actually fly,
we have our stagnation point pretty consistently
in this area,
where the cell openings also are, which makes perfect sense.
The separation point behaves exactly the opposite way.
So, when you brake more,
then the separation point moves —
the flow no longer follows the profile,
ever further forward,
with a bit of airflow.
Until eventually the whole top tears off,
and we no longer have any lift,
we're stalled,
and we're in a full stall.
Right, that's it for that —
what happens with the stagnation point and the separation point
when you change the angle of attack
and brake hard.
Then we can move on to wingtip vortices and drag.
Now we're getting heavily into drag,
let's look —
it's a whole topic.
We'll look at how drag is roughly distributed on the paraglider,
across the whole flying system.
Profile drag,
as you can see here,
is about 20 percent.
Lines are about 20 percent.
Pilot is about 20 percent.
And the largest part —
it's a bit difficult to picture,
because it's there,
but you can't actually see it.
It's induced drag.
And induced drag
is created at the wingtip,
because we have high pressure and low pressure.
And the pressures want to equalise,
they want to balance out somehow.
An imbalance is never good in nature or in physics.
Things always want to equalise somehow.
And at the wingtip you get turbulence.
Which can be quite strong sometimes,
so if you fly with a paraglider
very close behind another one,
then you'll notice
how it shakes you,
on landing approach,
definitely not recommended
for new pilots to fly behind
and better keep some distance.
It would be
if the aircraft is
above the paraglider,
or a Jumbo jet.
It's pretty heavy and they're the wingtip vortices.
That means,
if you want to land,
flying behind a tandem,
be very careful,
because the vortices are noticeably bigger,
than with a solo wing.
Now,
our goal,
as I said at the beginning,
is the ideal —
because we want
to have less drag,
more lift.
How can we get closer to that?
Looking at the profile,
we can take this a bit further.
Here,
as you've seen,
the wing has
all these cell bumps,
these waves and bulges,
where actually,
if you look at aircraft,
where the surface is nice and smooth,
this is actually quite inefficient
and not very favourable.
That's why high-performance wings,
or also intermediate wings,
the further up you go,
the more
the difficulty class,
the more cells the wing has.
And the cells essentially mean
that the waves
are as flat as possible,
so smaller waves rather
than large bulges,
we get much closer
to the ideal profile we're aiming for.
But this also requires
that you can master the wing,
handle it,
because it's just much harder
to fly.
Induced drag,
you reduce through aspect ratio (span).
On aircraft you also have winglets,
which you can see,
the next thing is the lines.
Here, of course, in the ideal case
you want as few lines as possible and as thin as possible,
which again brings with it
that things get tight,
that it's more demanding
to fly,
in case of disturbance,
and so on.
So you've seen,
all the factors
basically come down to this:
the wing becomes harder
to fly.
And needs much more know-how.
And last but not least,
pilot,
the harness,
of course also makes a huge difference,
whether we sit upright,
and present a large frontal surface to the wind,
or whether we lie down,
are as small as possible,
this also
makes a few percent difference,
where you can optimise.
I've drawn this quickly,
what a prone harness
approximately in the wind tunnel,
could look like.
So here too,
in the front,
as round as possible,
so the air particles
split nicely,
and flow around,
like with a raindrop,
and run along,
nicely behind.
In the ideal case
the harness has
a kind of tapered point at the back,
and it's not
any sharp edges,
where the flow tears off,
but really runs
into the slit,
or down to the tapered back end,
and then goes,
well,
rejoins at the back.
So that at the back
as little turbulence as possible
occurs.
And that way you can also
get the maximum out of it.
And by the way,
it's not just
that it's extremely comfortable,
and warm too.
Aerodynamically it really is
quite a big difference.
But also again,
more demanding to fly.
Now we can clear up the terminology.
First we talk about wingspan,
and what's also important to know
is that all the measurements
we're now discussing,
for the paraglider always come
as laid-out and projected.
Because laid out,
the wing is
much bigger,
than afterward,
when it's in the air.
So the outermost
two points,
are in the air
a bit smaller apart,
and what's
aerodynamically
interesting,
and the area
where it's in the air
measured,
above the head,
and producing lift,
is always the projected area.
But here,
sometimes,
you have to be careful
that you're using the same measure,
if someone says
yes, you have 20 square metres,
and then someone says,
yes, the 18,
and if you're not talking about the same measure,
or about the same,
yes,
then under some circumstances
you're describing
the same wing,
because one is talking about the laid-out,
span or area,
and the other the projected value.
Now we come to wing chord.
Here we always talk
about the mean wing chord,
because the wing chord at the stabiliser
or at the wingtip,
is much smaller than in the middle.
And that's why
we use the average
and call that
the mean wing chord.
And aspect ratio,
is
what actually makes a wing
more efficient,
because,
as we've seen,
induced drag,
is the biggest drag,
and with aspect ratio
you can actually,
reduce that,
it's the ratio
of the span
to the mean wing chord.
Now the mean wing chord,
you can't just measure directly.
It has to be a value
that the manufacturer provides.
You can,
if you look at the fraction,
whether the span
divided by mean wing chord.
Average,
you can expand the fraction
as well,
with span on top,
span on the bottom,
and then
you get span
squared, divided by area.
So either
span divided by mean wing chord
or span squared divided by area.
Divided by area.
And that's the aspect ratio.
Or it's slenderness.
Then we have one more clarification.
Projected area,
we'd already covered through the riser side
via the lines.
Or — better said,
or the projected area
is of course much further along.
If you're not at the landing site,
for example at the dealer,
and want to see this wing,
how big is its shadow.
So that should explain the projected area.